Richard Brookhiser went to work for
National Review full time in 1977 and
has been there ever since he has written
for many other magazines including the
New York Observer and then Palayam
technically in 1996 he published his
first biography founding father
rediscovering George Washington
most recently he is the author of the
right time right place
coming of age with William F Buckley Jr
and the conservative movement today he
will be speaking on the subject of his
upcoming book James Madison the father
of American politics please join me in
welcoming mr. Berger
Thank You grace thank you all for coming
out I just got this my first time at the
Kirby Center and I just got a little
tour of it before the talk and I think
it's it's a great thing for Hillsdale
students to have this here in Washington
it's a great thing for Hillsdale College
to get its profile out and its message
out and it's a great thing for friends
of Hillsdale because I love Hillsdale
but it's truly one of those places that
you can't get there from here
no matter where here is so for a New
Yorker who can just walk over from Union
Station I appreciate the convenience I'm
in the throws of the Madison book it is
not yet done but what I wanted to do
today was just read you the first
chapter which sets it up and gives an
overview of what will be the important
themes and also has some local interest
August 24th 1814 began as a typical
summer day in Washington bright and
cloudless promising heat and humidity as
the day wore on for years James Madison
the president had fled high summer in
Washington and other low-lying cities
for the healthier air of his inland home
in the Virginia Piedmont but this August
his presence was acquired required in
the capital America had been at war with
Britain for two years mr. Madison's war
he had asked Congress to declare it had
been fought along the Canadian border
against Indians on the frontier not in
the high seas now the war was coming
home a week earlier on August 17th
twenty British ships carrying 4,500
troops had anchored in the Patuxent
River in Maryland only 35 miles away
from Washington to the southeast the
President had suggested pelting the
enemy from the start with light troops
but nothing was done the British
debarked and made a leisurely stroll of
the Maryland countryside
perhaps bound for Baltimore the booming
port the third largest in America
Secretary of War John Armstrong thought
so they would certainly not come to
Washington who said what the devil will
they do here no no Baltimore is the
place sir now the British had made a
left turn just hours earlier at midnight
the president had gotten a note from the
field the enemy are in full march for
Washington destroy the bridges remove
the records when James Madison had been
a congressman a quarter century earlier
he'd helped move the nation's capital
from New York to an undeveloped site on
the Potomac the new Capitol was still
hardly more than a small town stretching
from Rock Creek in the West to Capitol
Hill in the east a ragged arc decorated
by a few incongruous public buildings as
if built by ancients or aliens in the
midst of it stood the White House
Madison was the third president to have
lived there John Adams whom Madison's
scorned had spent the dismal last days
of his administration in a shell inside
a construction site Thomas Jefferson who
Madison loved above all men ran at like
a Virginia plantation house the dinner
is Jefferson gave four congressmen and
diplomats provided good food excellent
wine and his own sparkling conversation
but they were small Affairs scaled so
that the master could shine Madison was
awkward with all but his intimates one
congressman's wife called him a gloomy
stiff creature but he had the good sense
to marry a superb hostess to make up for
it Dolly Madison brightened the White
House with dinners and soirees red
velvet curtains and green gilt-edged
China a piano and a macaw now a little
before 8 o'clock in the morning a
message came to this Republican palace
from General William winder in charge of
the city's
fans it was addressed to the Secretary
of War but the president opened it
himself the general wanted advice as
fast as possible
Madison mounted his horse and left the
White House for winders headquarters at
the Navy Yard the Navy Yard was a mile
south of town on the Eastern branch of
the Potomac now called the Anacostia
River there was a bridge there about
where the 11th Street bridge is now all
morning officers and cabinet secretaries
came and went the three most important
represented all the types that a
president typically finds about him in
moments of crisis men who might help men
who won't and men who can't James Monroe
Secretary of State had sent the midnight
warning about the British Maj a fellow
Virginian he had known Madison for
decades he had quarreled with him and
reconciled with him he had talent and
energy and he had decided to serve
Madison John Armstrong had been
appointed Secretary of War six months
after hostilities had begun to retrieve
the disasters of an incompetent
predecessor in a year and a half on the
job he cleared out Deadwood and promoted
fresh faces but he had also fallen out
with the president he had talent and
energy and had decided by August 1814 to
use neither Madison's behalf both Monroe
and Armstrong were Revolutionary War
veterans William winder a 39 year old
former lawyer had been in the Army for
two years and was assigned to defend the
Capitol in July largely because he was
the governor of Maryland's nephew he had
been unceasingly busy the innumerably
multiplied orders letters consultations
and demands which crowded upon me can
more easily be conceived than described
hero yet he had accomplished nothing
he had energy and no talent at all
the British were making for Bladensburg
Maryland a village north
to the capital there was a gap in the
hills there in a short bridge over the
Eastern branch five miles up from the
Navy Yard where the stream is narrow
it was the natural route for anyone
invading Washington from the east to
take Monroe Road off to alert whatever
American troops were already there
winder followed with reinforcements
Armstrong who came to the navy yard too
late was asked if he had any advice to
give he didn't but added that since the
battle would be between American militia
and British regulars the former would be
beaten
Madison suggested that Armstrong really
should take part in the coming
engagement I expressed to him my concern
and surprised that the reserve he showed
was how Madison recalled it Armstrong
added that if Madison thought it proper
he would go off to Bladensburg to the
president borrowed a set of pistols and
since his horse suddenly went lame a
second mount and decided to ride to
Bladensburg himself with his attorney
General Richard rush James Madison was
63 years old he had never heard a shot
fired in anger he was a small man just
over five feet tall just over a hundred
pounds and a sickly one all his life he
was subject to what he called a bilious
attacks upset stomach and bowels and
less often attacks resembling epilepsy
and suspending the intellectual
functions he had talent and energy in
spades he was smarter than Monroe
Armstrong and winder put together
smarter than Jefferson perhaps even
smarter than Adams he put his mind
forget his shoulder to the wheel driving
himself so hard that he often undermined
his already not robust Constitution but
he was not a warrior the day war was
declared he'd made himself ridiculous by
visiting the war in navy departments in
a little round hat and huge cockade a
rare violation of his nature it is
arguable and some of his contemporaries
argued at Madison's that representative
John Calhoun lacked the command
talents that he was not by nature an
executive but that morning he was chief
executive and commander-in-chief war was
five miles away and he rode to meet it
he and Rosh struck the road which is
still called Bladensburg Road overtaking
American units as they went after an
hour in the saddle they came down a hill
alongside an orchard and towards the
bridge that led over the eastern branch
to blatant Berg's main street and it's a
brick houses when an American Horseman
waved them back the president the
Attorney General had ridden ahead of
their own front line the British were
already entering the town from the
opposite direction winder Munro and
Armstrong were posted on the hill they
had just descended to the rear Madison
and Rush rode back toward them it was
now about one o'clock there were 7,000
Americans on or near the field a mixture
of militia and regulars plus 500 sailors
who were still marching with cannon from
the Navy Yard the Americans had been
arranged in three lines too close to the
Bladensburg bridge a third a mile
further back Monroe had altered some of
the dispositions at the last minute not
to advantage he pulled troops from the
orchard out into the fields where they
had no cover winder was frantic unable
to do anything himself
Madison asked Armstrong if he had done
anything the Secretary of War answered
that he had not I remarked wrote Madison
that he might offer some advice
Armstrong was not the only
passive-aggressive personality outside
Bladensburg that morning the two men
rode up to winder muskets and artillery
were already firing back and forth
across the stream at the rack at the
president's borrowed horse reared and
plunged so that Madison could not join
the conversation when the Secretary of
War in the general were done speaking
Madison asked Armstrong if he had
offered any advice Armstrong replied
that he hadn't and that the arrangements
appeared to be as good as circumstances
admitted what John Armstrong said
true the American arrangements for the
Battle of Bladensburg we're as good as
the circumstances which included the
abilities and deficiencies of the
commanders and the abilities and
deficiencies of the man who had given
them their jobs and kept them there
admitted the charm was wound up now the
battle for the Capitol would play out
the courage James Madison showed on the
morning of the Battle of Bladensburg is
what first prompted me to write about
him it was moral courage even more than
physical on a bad day that was about to
get worse he chose to see what was
happening and to face the consequences
of his actions but the war of 1812 is
not what people most associate with
Madison that is his role in producing
the Constitution Madison was called the
father of the Constitution during his
lifetime and he was born the title ever
since it's a misleading title if taken
too bluntly Madison was only one of
seven Virginia delegates to the
Constitutional Convention of 1787 one of
55 overall and did not get exactly the
document he wanted as the convention
wrapped up he worried in a letter to his
friend Jefferson in Paris that the
Constitution might not answer its
national object nor present the local
mischiefs which everywhere excite
discussed other men besides Madison made
essential contributions the Constitution
was written and its final form I
governor Morris the pegleg the delegate
from Pennsylvania a better choice for a
draftsman said Madison could not have
been made some of Madison's greatest
writing went into his arguments for the
Constitution and the Federalist Papers
but the on presario of that project was
Alexander Hamilton who picked the
authors Madison and John Jay in addition
to himself and wrote three-fifths of the
85 papers the strongest argument for the
Constitution was the presence of George
Washington at the convention and is
quiet support afterwards
Madison understood that Washington was
the heavyweight champion of American
public life which is why he stuck by him
like a trainer from the planning stages
of the convention through the early days
of Washington's presidency finally the
resistance of the Constitution's
opponents like Madison's enemy Patrick
Henry obliged the Constitution's
supporters to offer something that they
as authors had neglected to provide a
bill of rights but only Madison played a
central role at every stage in the
Constitution's birth he was present
before at and after the creation he was
a delegate to the Annapolis convention
of 1786 which called for the convention
in Philadelphia a year later when the
Philadelphia Convention met in 1787 he
arrived the first out-of-towner to show
up with an agenda in mind he never
missed a session and he spoke more often
than any other delegate except the
flashy Morris and James Wilson another
Pennsylvania he always comes forward
wrote William Pierce of Georgia the best
informed man on any point in debate
thanks to the Federalist Papers
published in New York he was a player
and the fight for ratification in that
state and he led the pro-constitution
forces in Virginia political reality and
Jefferson's urging persuaded Madison to
accept the idea of a Bill of Rights and
as a member of the first Congress he
threw himself into that project with
characteristic energy sorting the
proposals of earnest idealist and secret
saboteurs into something like the first
ten amendments we have today plus
amendment 27 proposed in 1789 but not
ratified until 1992 he was finally the
first historian of the Constitutional
Convention determined to preserve the
process the principles the reasons and
the anticipations of the framers he
posted himself every day in front of the
head table in
independence all in this favorable
position for hearing all that passed I
noted what was read from the chair or
spoken by the members and losing not a
moment unnecessarily between the
adjournment and reassembling of the
convention I was enabled to write out my
daily nose madison's nose the most
complete set left by any delegate have
been grist for later historians ever
since Madison
earned his paternity of the Constitution
he was a devoted and anxious parent for
he believed that the happiness of the
people great even in its infancy and
possibly the cause of Liberty throughout
the world were staked on what he and his
colleagues had made the Constitution was
not the only subject that engrossed
Madison's relentless mind however in the
late 1780s were not his only active
years he was a precocious young man
unlike many hypochondriacs he lived to
be a very old one and he devoted his
long adulthood to analyzing the cause of
Liberty in 1776 age 25 he led the fight
to amend the Virginia Declaration of
right from guaranteeing fullest
toleration of religion to free exercise
toleration is a gift truly free man
exercised their rights
Madison's statement of principle was
enacted into law by the statute of
Virginia for religious freedom written
by Jefferson who was so proud of it that
he mentioned it on his tombstone but it
was Madison who got Jefferson's law
through the Virginia assembly I flatter
myself Madison wrote Jefferson
afterwards that we have extinguished
forever the ambitious hope of making
laws for the human mind in 1791 after
the Constitution was ratified Madison
sat down to rethink some of the most
important debates he had just won in the
Federalist he'd argued that the very
size of the United States would buttress
Liberty since malign factions could not
seize power in such a dispersed country
but he had also argued that another
guarantee was
necessary enlightened public opinion in
a new series of essays published like
the Federalist in the newspapers he
teased out the consequences of this idea
drowning in poll data we understand the
importance of public opinion though we
often doubt how enlightened it is but in
the early 1790s regularly consulting
public opinion was a new concept many of
Madison's colleagues including
Washington and Hamilton had little use
for it they thought that people should
rule when they voted then let the
victors do their best until the next
election
Madison limps our world before it
existed Madison was consumed with
questions of war and peace he had to be
the Bastille fell during his first year
in the first Congress and the war is
touched off by the French Revolution
continued through the war of 1812 the
United States began its national life in
the shadow of a world war as violent as
World Wars one and two longer than both
of them put together and as ideological
as the Cold War it was ironic that
Madison asked for war in 1812 and found
himself on a battlefield two years later
he feared wars the enemy of Liberty and
had tried as Jefferson's Secretary of
State then as president to avoid it
surely he believed trade was a more
powerful weapon than arms yet when he
felt America's honour was compromised
he chose war both his attitudes pacifism
and touchiness wind through later
American history in his long retirement
almost twenty years
Madison grappled with questions of
slavery and Union he heard the coming of
the Civil War decades before Fort Sumter
his solutions to the problem of slavery
were worthless a pathetic case of
intellectual and moral failure his
position on the problem of Union would
help solve the problem of slavery but
Madison is more than the father of the
Constitution or of other intellectual
constructs he is the father of politics
he lived in his head
but his head was
always concerned with making his
cherished thoughts real in a free
country the road to reality runs through
politics
Madison spent as much time politicking
as thinking and he was equally good at
it he did what came naturally to him
preparation persuasion agenda setting
committee work parliamentary maneuvering
he grew up in a family as large as an
oyster bed good training for a future
legislator he worked at what did not
come naturally to him
public speaking campaigning his voice
was both harsh and weak time and again
the note takers at debates he
participated in left blanks in his
remarks or simply gave up because mr.
Madison could not be distinctly heard
yet when circumstances required that he
debated Patrick Henry he debated James
Monroe in the open air in a snowstorm so
bitter he got frostbite on his nose he
won both debates when he found a
political chore he absolutely could not
do he was not too proud to work with men
or women who could Dolly Madison was
more than a hostess she was a political
wife America's first half a campaign
tag-team and often the better half
George Clinton one of Madison's many
rivals was a widower when it came time
for them to clash Madison wrote one
senator has a wife to aid in his
pretensions whereas Clinton has nothing
of female sucker on his side and in
these two respects mr. animus going
greatly ahead of him Madison worked with
Washington profiting from his charisma
and his judgment and with Hamilton
profiting from his - when he was not
alarmed by it he worked with Jefferson
visionary philosopher and politician par
excellence for 40 years he consented to
learn something about money from his
younger colleague Albert Gallatin a
Swiss immigrant who spoke with a French
accent but knew more about America's
finances and
natives Madison was a great man who is
not afraid of assisting or deferring to
other great men another legacy of his
tight family life he also worked with
the less than great hatchet men and
gossips snooze and spies on one occasion
he turned a blind eye to a mob they do
the work of politics too they are part
of the game
Madison invented political institutions
as lasting as the Constitution he helped
found America's first political party
the Republicans in nearly seventeen 90s
later they changed their name to the
Democrats the modern GOP is an unrelated
organization who still hold Jefferson
Jackson Day dinners to commemorate their
origins they should know that their
party began in 1791 when Madison joined
Jefferson on a trip through New York and
New England supposedly collecting
biological specimens for the American
Philosophical Society actually
collecting allies for themselves
Madison helped found the first party
newspaper the National Gazette the
nation the New Republic National Review
Fox and MSNBC are latter-day
incarnations he recruited the papers
first editor Philip for now an old
college chum who dabbled in poetry
Jefferson gave Forno a nominal job as a
translator in the State Department and
in his free time
for now smacked Hamilton and Washington
in prose Madison's interest in publicity
flowed naturally from his interest in
public opinion such a powerful force
could not be allowed to develop randomly
or to be molded by Liberty's enemies if
enlightened public opinion was a bulwark
of freedom than leaders must labor
ceaselessly to enlighten or manipulate
it Madison belonged to an early form of
the political machine
the dynasty America had revolted against
George the 3rd in the House of Hanover
but the dynastic temptation is always
strong John Adams second president and
only founder president with sons saw his
eldest John Quincy Adams become the
sixth president but the Addamses were
unpopular one termers between them
stretched the Virginia dynasty to terms
of Jefferson to terms of Madison to
terms of Monroe 24 years of government
by neighbors and ideological soulmates
one of the iron laws of politics is that
what goes around comes around throughout
his career Madison was beset by enemies
and supposed friends wielding the same
dark arts that he practiced fortunately
for him he was generally skillful enough
to beat them back but another iron law
of politics is that you can't win them
all heroes can aspire to perfection
especially if they die young through the
purity of an action or a stance but the
long haul of politics takes at least
some of the shine off almost everyone
Madison had an unusually good record
when it came to winning elections not
quite so good when it came to sizing up
issues and men and the years would see
many achievements as well as rigidities
and blunders we pay much less attention
to James Madison father of politics than
to James Madison father of the
Constitution
that's because politics embarrasses us
politics is the spectacle on television
and YouTube the daily perp-walk on the
Huffington Post and the Drudge Report
surely our founders and framers left us
something better more solid more
inspiring than that they did but they
all knew and Madison understood better
than any of them that ideals come to
life and dozens of political
transactions every day some of those
transactions aren't pretty
you can understand this and try to work
with this man
or you can look away but ignoring
politics will not make it stop it will
simply go on without you and sooner or
later happen to you
Dali painted in the first excitement of
meeting a possible suitor her future
husband told a friend the great little
Madison had asked to see me this evening
all his life
Madison's acquaintances rang the changes
on this contrast he was a mighty figure
and a little guy
the contrast has a moral dimension to
James Madison was a great man who helped
build a republic he was also an
ambitious and sometimes small bore man
who stumped spoke counted votes pulled
wires scratch backs and stabbed them he
would not be afraid of the contrast for
his deepest thinking told him that the
builders of Liberty had to know and
sometimes use the materials of passion
and self-advancement if wars the
continuation of politics by other means
it makes sense to introduce Madison on a
battlefield even a dubious one Americans
ignore him there too because we divide
our wars into two categories those we
look back on as stirring Washington's
crossing Pickett's Charge d-day and
those we look back on as unseemly or
botched or both but our present
experience of Afghanistan and Iraq may
illuminate the war of 1812 there were
miscalculations and disasters in mr.
Madison's war but there were also
moments of valor discipline and learning
from mistakes even if Bladensburg with
Madison Road to Bladensburg more than 60
years into his life forty years into his
career
let us begin at the beginning and so
when I finished the book will be able to
read what comes now
thank you
now now unlike speakers of the
constitutional convention or the
Virginia ratifying convention I have to
take questions so we have a microphone
so I'll recognize you and then wait for
the man in the back who has the
microphone to come yes sir
oh yes that was where that was where the
models for inventions that had been
submitted for patents were stored and
that was in a hotel by Capitol Hill and
the man who was the head of the Patent
Office the British were about to torch
it and he you know he addressed the
commanding officer and said you can't do
this in a senior officer was summoned
and he told them that you know if they
did this this would be like the burning
of the Library of Alexandria you know
would go down in history as a great blow
not just against America but against
human advancement so that building was
so spared
I haven't seen that one if it was a
private house they might have missed it
the sailors did the best job not the
Marines but the sailors did the best job
at Bladensburg I mentioned those 500
sailors who were marching to the field
and they were the they were the only
ones who held to their positions and
they were banned at it at their guns I
mean they they performed very nobly and
actually it was Madison's idea to send
them there their orders were to blow up
the the bridge the 11th Street bridge
and the commander said look you can have
six people do that you don't need 500
people to blow up the bridge my men want
to fight so Madison said well you know
come on along them and and they were the
they were the only troops who were well
disciplined and stuck to their post
there was a question in the back
well that is the $64,000 question about
Madison and his biographers tend to be
in two camps and the larger camp and
obviously because if you're a mat if
you're devoting time to Madison you
become as a li and his friend and you
want to think well of him in as many
ways as possible so the larger number of
them take the view that there is a
consistency throughout Madison's career
and we just have to figure out what it
is the the smaller the smaller group
says well you know no there there really
isn't that kind of close consistency and
I tend to be in the latter group but but
I also say what's the problem you know
look at the man's job the man was a
politician and politics is always
sending you new situations and surprises
and you have to react to them if you
know Hamilton had had a had laid out a
financial program you know at the
Constitutional Convention at the time
when they were like this you know maybe
maybe Madison would have become alarmed
earlier but Hamilton hadn't because well
I do it I mean we're not there yet but
then the Constitution is passed and then
we are there now so what will our
financial program be Hamilton has his
ideas based on his knowledge his
experience Madison has his own set of
ideas based on his own experience and I
would say relative lack of knowledge but
they certainly weren't his own peculiar
ideas they were shared by many of his
peers and friends and
Virginia and so the first two-party
system in American history is generated
also the French Revolution doesn't begin
until 1789 and how do we react to this
it's a new it's a new thing I mean we're
all like scratching our heads about
Egypt now right well this this was
bigger I mean France was one of the
super powers of the world one of the two
was also our ally is the only superpower
that like this and suddenly they have a
revolution so what do we say about that
is this a great thing you know they're
getting on board with our ideals and our
project or is this maybe not gonna work
out so well and the founding fathers
split on that question so I you know I
see that the search for consistency and
constancy in sort of every jot and
tittle of what Madison wrote maybe maybe
sort of the pursuit of the wrong
question and I don't although I do see
areas of inconsistency
I don't underrate him or downgrade and
because of that I mean I disagree with
certain policy decisions that he made
and certainly was in impulses but I
don't you know I don't knock points off
from him very much if at all on the
question of consistency because that's
what that's what politics is all about
yes sir wait wait for the microphone I
can hear you but for c-span we need to
to preserve this for the agents we need
think of this as James Madison taking
notes
mmm-hmm well I think Madison was not by
nature an executive he is by nature a
legislator and and that's where his
earliest work and his greatest work was
done and I do see a pattern in his
presidency he knows who the screw-ups
and the incompetence who were working
with him and for him are he figures that
out pretty quickly and he does get rid
of all of them he ends up getting rid of
all of them he carries some of them for
an awful long time and a friend of mine
Michael pack gave me an insight which
he's gonna he earned an acknowledgement
in the book from this he said well
that's what legislators do you know
because the legislators building a
coalition and and you know every
coalition has you know idiots and
incompetence you know but each one of
them has a vote they all have a vote so
you have to you know you have to know
how to draw them in and work with them
and so on
an executive is interested in doing a
job and so so an incompetent is sheer
deadweight you know and so you're
looking for ways you're always there may
be reasons you you have these guys but
you're always looking for ways to keep
them away from responsibility to get rid
of them - you know shuffle them off to
the side and it takes Madison an awful
lot like John Armstrong who was not an
incompetent Secretary of War that I
mentioned not an incompetent that he
ends up you know just disliking this and
working under mine so why does Madison
keep him so long well that's a good
question
the having said all that we do emerge
from the war of 1812 as a draw
and since we're the Punky second-rate
power and Britain has beaten Napoleon a
draw like that counts as a victory
you know Tacitus has one of
Germans say that the Romans made a
desert and called it peace
well Madison made a draw and called it
victory I think it was entitled to do
that and and I think the the fact the
United States survived the war of 1812
and emerged at the other end
no worse than they'd gone into it I mean
the final peace term for status quo ante
it yeah it calmed Americans down because
a lot of the rancor of the early
republic I think was related to a sense
of insecurity would this new country
really work would it really survive and
everybody's made very frantic by this
and this affects partisanship because
nobody really believes in his bones that
if he loses he's going to have another
chance now we all know that we all
really do know that if you lose there's
two years from now there's four years
from now there's eight years from now
they didn't it was the theory you know
it was in the Constitution but they
didn't like really really know that and
then finally thanks in part to Madison
we come out the other end of the war of
1812 in pretty good shape and Americans
they're relieved for one thing but it's
also like yeah we did this we emerged on
the other side and this is why we have
what is called the era of good feelings
then of course we have the run-up to the
Civil War so problems come worse
problems come back in different forms
but at least there is a sort of a sense
of resolution and I think Madison
deserves some credit for that yes sir
the man in the striped sweater
well separation of powers was obviously
it was a topic that engaged
Madison's thought for a long time and I
think one of his great
maybe greatest insights as a political
thinker is that the very complication of
American politics and political
structure is a good thing and will
preserve it and strengthen it and this
seemed to fly in the face of the opinion
of Montesquieu who was everybody's
favorite political philosopher and
America in the late 18th century and he
said Republic's have to be small if
they're large they fail the Roman
Republic became the Roman Empire and
that's just the pattern of it the
Republic has to be a city state and
Madison also Hamilton but Madison
pre-eminently says no the the fact that
were so big that there are 13 states
that this is like a continental sized
country that they're all these different
religions they're all these different he
didn't use the word cultures but that's
what he meant all these different
localities and the fact that we have
different branches of government in the
federal level and the fact that we have
state governments against you know under
or and/or against the federal government
this is a good thing this strengthens
the Republic okay now in terms of the
war of 1812 Madison has has pretty good
control over Congress the the war is
usually credited to the war hawks which
were the the Young Turks of the of the
12th Congress men like Henry Clay and
John Calhoun and we're just getting into
national life Calvin for the first time
and they really they want to do
something great themselves it's really a
generational thing clay gives this this
very interesting speech about how you
know the founders they're still with us
but they're old and you know they're all
there says week I think but he says we
need we need our own achievements our
own triumphs it's really a generational
thing
but of course Madison by this point
Madison also wants it to happen he's not
dragged into war by the Warhawks
I think he's every bit as interested in
smiting Britain by this point and also
remember Madison is a lifelong anger
folk and a lifelong Francophile and this
this affects his judgments throughout
his career so it wasn't so much a
separation of powers issue as you know I
think the the two the two factors were a
talented deficit you know our senior
officers were like broken-down
Revolutionary veterans and Winfield
Scott who was one of the great military
men who came out of this war he wrote
memoirs late in life yes to them
delightful descriptions of what the
American army was like in 1811 1812 and
he just you know he just had contempt
for all his older peers and he he said
in the he has this long description and
he says this shows the danger of letting
imbeciles and ignoramus direct the
military of a republic so there was that
problem and a lot of these guys got
cleaned out in the first six months
because they were just they were just
terrible then the other problem was
money the Congress had gotten rid of the
first bank of the United States in 1811
mrs. Hamilton's Bank it had a 20-year
Charter came up in 1811 by this time
Madison who had opposed it
who'd fought it tooth and nail now
accepts it as a both constitutional and
useful and his Treasury Secretary Albert
Gallatin really led him to that thought
but there's enough resistance and
skepticism in Congress all of it from
his own party
that the bank is not reach our turd so
where would will the United States be
turning for money there are three
options there's tear
revenues and there's loans and there's
taxes well we're not going to get many
tariff revenues if we go to war against
the strongest naval power in the world
which is also our main trading partner
so tariff revenues will go down taxes
the Republicans Madison's party are the
low tax party so they're reluctant to
raise them loans we no longer have a
Bank of the United States so it becomes
harder to raise loans also Federalist
bankers who are anti-war are not going
to give loans to a Republican
administration it's a real nasty
partisan split so we really by the end
of the war we're stumbling along broke I
mean we've got our military in good
shape and it's really effective by the
war's end
but thankfully the war ends when it does
or we would truly you know gone on the
block because we were out of money yes
sir in the back
sorry to make you run around
well he does he does make some changes
but I don't think historians do not
think he was a big rewriter they don't
take it very seriously he he keeps his
convention notes not secret exactly but
he does not publish them throughout his
life he does show them to friends I mean
he almost certainly shows to Jefferson
Hamilton's long six-hour speech where he
called for a president elected for life
and you know senators elected for life
and I'm I'm sure they were passing that
back and forth almost like pornography
no but but he's very careful not to
reveal his his notes partly because he
doesn't want to be embroiled in in
controversies over what he said I mean
he said some very anti states rights
things in Philadelphia himself and he
doesn't want to be you know shot at
because of those statements of his but
he also understands as a matter of
rhetorical effectiveness that if these
notes are posthumous they come out after
he's dead and you know certainly he
realizes at a certain point I'm one of
the last guys left standing then by the
end he is the last he's the last of the
framers and then he knows well and after
I'm dead I'll be beyond the last and
these notes will have an even greater
impact so he's very careful to husband
them now another set appears in 1821 by
one of the anti-federalists Robert Yates
who walked out in the middle of the
summer he was one of two New Yorkers it
was Hamilton plus two anti-federalists
and John Lansing and Robert Yates took
off because they thought this was to
ante States right so it was happening in
Philadelphia and his notes were
published in 1820 and they were probably
tampered with actually there was citizen
janae
name rings a bell he married one of
George Clinton's daughters so he's
living in New York State you know four
years after him broiled American
diplomacy in the 1790s and so he's a
Clinton guy which means he's an T
Madison so he like sort of tweak some of
Madison's remarks and the aides as notes
so Madison was unhappy to to have these
notes appear but he will not answer them
with his own and I think he was right
you know holding back they'll have even
more effect
yes yes ma'am I just wait for here he
comes
wellhe one aspect of his being in this
great big family was that he was a great
student not only was he a great worker
with peers but he was he was every
teachers favorite student and he was
certainly the favorite student of John
Witherspoon who was the president of the
college of new jersey and Witherspoon
loved to say and he apparently said it
more than once that Madison was his best
student he never knew him to do a a
dishonourable or a disagreeable thing
now one of the people he said this to
was Thomas Jefferson Jefferson loved
this story and he would repeat it to
tease Madison you know and because he
knew that Madison know in private
Madison had a vein of racy talk he just
did and we have this testified by all
kinds of people over the years and when
Madison was a student at Princeton one
thing the kids did is they wrote abusive
poems about each other you know what
it's look it's not it's not it is very
mild stuff by today's standards but it's
like chamberpot jokes and all this kind
of 18th century you know to buy a small
sort of humor and and so Madison would
be writing these poems and people would
write them back and it was a student
thing Shirley Witherspoon could have
known about this right but this shows
you Madison's ability he can be the
teacher's pet and then he can turn
around be one of the boys and then the
third fold there is Jefferson repeating
this story to embarrass Madison for
years he can also be Jefferson's good
friend who doesn't care that his older
brother friend is like teasing him
constantly
he'll just you'll just roll with that I
mean Madison was a great associate great
friend to have he he was devoted to his
friends mostly loyal to them stuck by
them he certainly is loyal to Washington
even
after Washington cuts him off because
there does come a moment when Washington
is fed up with Madison's later politics
and he cuts him off and they only needed
a few state functions after that and
it's really he just slammed down the
gate and that was it but Madison never
cut Washington off and when Washington
dies Madison is back in the Virginia
assembly and he makes the motion it's
very moving he says as we were the first
to recognize his merits we will not be
the last to regret his passing that's an
eloquent you know impromptu remark that
he gives so he holds on to his affection
for Washington even after they split now
the one he doesn't do that with his
Hamilton of course but that's a whole
that's a whole other question one more
question yes sir
yes
well it is true if you read I mean
Federalist tennis the classic but it
comes up in other papers and he really
discusses faction as a you know a source
of a potential source of real problems
and therefore it has to be managed and
controlled but he he does know that
factions are going to appear the thing
in fact that they must appear they're
inevitable that the only way to prohibit
them is to get rid to abolish Liberty
you know if you polish Liberty you'll
get rid of factions but obviously we
can't do that that would be a solution
far worse than the disease so he's
almost like a like a scientist studying
germs in a lab you know and he's got all
these test tubes of the germs and he's
studying them that he keeps his gloves
on but then as as you say and as I was
trying to argue in this chapter and
we'll be arguing in the book he's also
in the test tube's himself I mean he's
doing it himself and I have to say I
think you know his understanding of this
is not static it develops and he does
see you know once Hamilton starts
getting his financial program going and
Madison is alarmed by an alarmed by the
fact that Washington is backing it and
he wants to oppose it he wants to you
know resist and so he and Jefferson
found a party now their original thought
is well once we win the party will
wither away which of course it doesn't
but you know Madison lives the long life
and he he learns and he goes through
things and he sees the shape that things
are taking and I think it's to his
credit that he keeps himself open to
learning and to learning not just from
books that he reads and he's a great
reader but also from his own experiences
I mean here's the guy who's very
intellectual very theoretical but he's
not just going to apply some template
that he mastered in 1787 and just try
and like smacking on everything forever
he's willing in many cases not all but
in many cases to modify it and to you
know sort of roll with the punches and I
think that's how that speaks to his I
think it speaks to his patience I think
it speaks to his persistence which is
probably what I must admire about him
this is the man who never quits and if
he loses he'll come back the next day
you know if you lose a vote get on the
committee to implement the vote there's
hope you know or you know even if it's
worse than that you can always come back
you can always keep coming back and he
does and part of what enables him to do
it is a willingness to submit his ideas
to the test of his life and see you know
what ensues okay I was told that was the
last question but thank you very much
you